au lendemain de la tragique erreur qui a
conduit à la destruction en vol d'un
airbus d'iranair avec 290 personnes à
bord c'est la consternation dans le
monde à grande bretagne et israël n'ont
pas remis en question le droit des états
unis à se défendre la france et l'italie
réclament d'urgence une solution à la
guerre du golfe les pays arabes
riverains du golfe sont pour l'instant
silencieux et l'iran menace nous y
reviendrons
avant cela comment le croiseur us s20
celles chargées de la protection anti
aériennes at il été amené à tirer deux
missiles sur un avion civil iranien qui
l'a mal identifié et bien selon les
responsables de la marine américaine
c'est environ une demi heure après le
début des combats entre le croiseur
américain et des vedettes iraniennes que
les radars américains détecte un
appareil qui s'approche à grande vitesse
et c'est alors la tragique méprise les
américains pensent qu'il s'agit d'un
avion militaire
jérôme bonnet les recherches se
poursuivent en ce moment même dans les
eaux du golfe pour tenter de retrouver
les corps des victimes opérations
difficiles l'appareil si pulvérisé sous
l'impact des deux missiles tirés par la
marine américaine
les vedettes iraniennes ont déjà repêché
150 cadavres sur les 290 victimes parmi
lesquelles 66 enfants
cette catastrophe est intervenue alors
que les incidents avaient repris dans le
golfe où la marine américaine a toujours
pour mission de protéger les navires
marchands vendredi soir attaque
irakiennes contre un pétrolier grec près
de l'île de kharg samedi attaques de
vedettes iraniennes contrat supertanker
danois près de l'île d'abou moussa
dimanche matin enfin des vedettes
rapides iranienne attaque un hélicoptère
du croiseur américain us s vincennes
deux vedettes iraniennes sont coulés un
peu plus tard une heure après selon les
iraniens
l'airbus a300 du vol iranair 655 téhéran
dubaï d'école de son escale de bandar
abbas
il est 10h 47 l'appareil entre dans le
champ des radars du croiseur vincennes
qui selon le pentagone lui demande à
trois reprises de s'identifier
selon radio téhéran le pilote ne
signalent rien d'anormal dans son
dernier message à la tour de contrôle
il semblerait que les rebuts
vol bien dans le couloir aérien
contrairement à ce qu a d'abord affirmé
le capitaine du croiseur will rogers
par ailleurs on s'explique mal comment
un bâtiment aussi sophistiqué que le
vincennes
l'un des fleurons de la marine
américaine spécialisée dans la détection
courtier aérienne a pu faire la
confusion entre un airbus et un chasseur
iranien f14 à 10h54 le croiseur
américain tire deux missiles sol air
l'avion est abattu à dubaï les amis des
passagers après la tragique nouvelle
il n'y a pas un seul survivant